taugourdeau merci je suis un peu moins
de bruit dans les travées monsieur le
premier ministre
mais question toujours le même fil la
création de travail en france c'est la
meilleure façon de lutter contre le
chômage
pensez vous vous rapprochez de la france
qui se lève tôt en allant samedi soir
sur le plateau de on n'est pas couché
monsieur le premier ministre
cette émission cette émission qui ne
sert pas la grandeur de l'engagement
politique et peut être intéressante pour
le socialiste manuel valls
mais ce n'est surtout pas le place du
premier ministre de la france ne nous
dit pas que le président de la
république va y aller aussi comment
créer du travail avec des grands projets
bloqués dans des zones à défendre comme
notre dame des landes
comment créer du travail en disant qu'on
va simplifier mais sans toucher au
contrat de travail sans toucher au temps
de travail ni aux modes de licenciement
dire et ne pas faire avouer que c'est
malheureusement votre marque de fabrique
et celle de votre gouvernement vos
ministres sont-ils ministre ou agent
double on dit blanc mais on fait bleu ou
rouge selon la tendance où les sondages
de la vienne peut-être les visions
hallucinatoires de votre ministre du
travail sur la courbe du chômage alors
tout de même félicitations monsieur le
premier ministre votre communication
c'est quand même de la très haute
cuisine c'est digne de top chef
mais malheureusement pour la france et
les français c'est plutôt cauchemar en
cuisine
ma première question est simple monsieur
le premier ministre
quand comptez-vous créer du travail en
france
monsieur le premier ministre je vais
vous mettre très à l'aise si vous ne
savez pas comment crée du travail en
france ne dit rien laissé répondre un de
vos ministres mac seconde question est
toute simple
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres quand allez vous
enfin joindre les actes à la parole
merci la parole et à monsieur jean marie
le guen secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président à la mz et
messieurs les députés monsieur le groupe
les cours d'eau il ya un peu trop pris
en charge des relations avec le
parlement j'essaye en général de
valoriser le travail de tous les
parlementaires
s'agissant des questions de l'emploi que
vous avez à de façon très intermittente
traité à travers votre question de la
question du travail qui est un sujet
majeur pour notre société mais que vous
avez distribué dans des propos à la fois
incohérent ça je vous renvoie évidemment
à votre propre réflexion
mais surtout une certaine forme de
légèreté d'ironique déplacés qui me
semble-t-il n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
que les français attendent d'un député
de l'opposition lorsqu'il s'agit de
poser la question de l'emploi et du
travail
monsieur le député aujourd'hui les
français nous regardent ils sont
effectivement interrogatif sur la
question de l'emploi parce qu'ils
veulent une mobilisation des partenaires
ils veulent une mobilisation de l'état
et du gouvernement ils veulent une
action volontaire qui soit capable de
bouger effectivement un certain nombre
de tabous et c'est ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui avec les propositions qui
ont été celles du président de la
république se plante d'urgence
économique et social sur lequel il veut
mobiliser et l'apprentissage et la
formation lpr moyens pour des grands
travaux et aussi à travers une action
législative qui sera portée par me
ramène conneries dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent qui feront que
tout ce que vous n'avez pas été capable
de faire pendant des années nous le
mettrons en actions pour lutter en
faveur de l'emploi et la revalorisation
du travail
merci la parole et à monsieur alain
rousset